Devon you nez's four-page memo looks
like it won't be the last
Declassified document to shake up
Congress the house Intel committee just
voted unanimously to release a
democratic counter memo one that seeks
to rebutting surgeons in the four pages
that Nunez released on Friday if you're
keeping up with this we should be able
to see the new memo soon and no matter
what it says that's probably a good
thing for everybody for the first time
in generations Americans have reason to
believe that our intelligence and law
enforcement agencies gravely misused the
powers we have given them violating the
civil liberties of Americans and taking
sides in political contests well you
can't trust a government that would do
something like that and many Americans
don't that is a disaster in a democracy
where the trust of the population is key
the transparency is the only antidote to
that so release all the documents all
relevant documents and let the rest of
us decide what they mean maybe that'll
make us trust our government again
nothing else will
well Democrats disagree with that just
last week party leaders and their
lackeys in the media were yelling at the
rest of us about how releasing the Nunez
memo would constitute a deadly threat to
America they said that for days and then
the memo came out whatever you think of
the memos conclusions you got to be
honest and concede there was not a
single thing in there that you should
not have been allowed to see there were
no classified weapons programs discussed
no names of secret agents revealed
Democrats it turns out didn't want it
released because it might embarrass them
so when Friday we spoke to California
congressman Eric SWA well he's a member
of the House Intelligence Committee
right in the center of this and we asked
him the obvious question none of this
should have been secret in the memo why
did you fight to keep it hidden
well swallow it didn't answer that
question instead he accused us of
betraying our country here's part of the
exchange we had in the case of today's
memo what specifically have I espoused
that empowers threats to our country
you're peddling the narrative that the
Trump administration is putting out
which also is the Putin narrative
because they're retweeting this with
their Russian BOTS this
same wiki lychee and do you pursue the
same size WikiLeaks and Putin you should
take a step back and wonder who's
betting are you really doing who's
bidding are you really doing so for
wanting to you see the memo we are
treasonous agents of Vladimir Putin you
probably grew up reading about the
McCarthy era where demagogues in
Congress made baseless claims of foreign
collusion destroying the lives of
American citizens in the process and
probably didn't think you'd live to see
it happen again but it has about a year
ago we spoke to another Democratic
member of the House Intelligence
Committee Adam Schiff of California and
we asked him another obvious and
straightforward question what evidence
do you have that the Russian government
hacked John Podesta's email account
often alleged never proved so we pushed
Schiff got squirrely we pushed him again
here's what happened can you look right
into the camera and say I know for a
fact the government of Vladimir Putin
was behind the hacks of John Podesta
absolutely the government of Vladimir
Putin was behind the hacks of our
institution and the dumb bug of John
Podesta is not only in the but also in
Europe okay you're not you know what
your dog said Tucker look and say well I
know they did John past and I think that
Ronald rolling around Reagan you're
carrying water for the Kremlin you're
sitting in somebody and you can't say
they Hawk you're gonna have to move your
shoulder to RT Russian television
carrying water for the Kremlin
disloyalty to America treason in a
single year on this show we've been
accused of betraying our own country by
more than 20% of the Democrats in the
House Intelligence Committee what is
this about part of it obviously is
politics of the most cynical kind the
Democratic base has been fed Russian
conspiracy theories for months now and
they're primed to believe literally
anything on that subject without within
hours of appearing on this show last
week Eric swallow was out raising money
on our quote attack on the rule of law
our questions weren't attacking the rule
of law by the way well that's
dishonorable and untrue but at least it
makes a kind of sense in a sleazy
Washington way
but what if these guys are actually
starting to believe the lies they tell
in a speech last week Adam Schiff
accused Russia of a crime so bizarre
that even the most diabolical soviet-era
leaders never would have dared attempt
it watch this
they also trumpeted the Second Amendment
apparently the Russians are very big
fans of our Second Amendment they don't
particularly want a second Amendment of
their own but they're really glad that
we have one the Russians would be
thrilled if we were doing nothing but
killing each other every day and sadly
we are so if you're following along at
home how determined are the Russians to
destroy American democracy well so
determines as congressman Schiff that
they will even attempt to promote our
own Bill of Rights next thing you know
they'll be reprinting the Federalists oh
the Slovak mind dastardly this is
demented and there's no other word for
it
it grows of course from our ruling
classes unwillingness to face the
lessons of last year's election voters
rejected them they can't accept that
they blame Russia we get it but at what
cost
all of this Schiff and swallow are not
college professors they're not CNN
anchors their members are one of the
most powerful and important committees
in the Congress one charged with
overseeing our vast intelligence
apparatus they're supposed to be sober
and thoughtful and smart but they're not
instead if you dare ask an uncomfortable
question they accuse you of working for
a hostile foreign dictator strictly
speaking that's a death-penalty offense
by the way this is your opposition party
these are the people who are supposed to
be giving us an alternative to trump who
they claim is too irresponsible to rule
but they're more irresponsible and
they're angrier and they're more
reckless and most terrifying at all they
are poised to take power nine months
from right now at the midterms they may
chances are in fact they'll be running
Congress again these people the ones who
cavalierly accuse fellow Americans of
treason who mock civil liberties who
believe the US Constitution itself is
some kind of Russian ploy
they'll be in charge Adam Schiff will be
chairman of the Intel committee if there
was ever incentive for the Republicans
to get their act together seriously and
do it fast you just saw it